- Hey guys, went to Cannes for three,
for a week, actually, at
the marketing festival
in the south of France.
What you're about to see is
the correlation of three days,
jammed up, highlight reel.
Hope you enjoy it.
(upbeat music)
(yelling)
You got your perspective.
(crowd roars)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] Gary, you're
Most Valuable Creator.
- Bless you.
(laughter)
I would go with self-awareness.
I think that we need to put that word
on a much bigger cultural pedestal.
Really getting to a place
where you understand yourself,
and I would say self-awareness
needs to be like oxygen.
It's a 24/7 thing.
When you're 22,
and you're wide-eyed and bushy-tailed,
there's something that you really want.
Then, at 26 you fall in love
and you want a different,
you gotta really check that at all times.
What are you up to?
Is it about currency?
Is it about legacy?
Is it about fulfillment?
Work-life balance?
I'm sure everybody here
has gone through one cycle
of going all-in but then
looking for more balance
and then going back all-in,
so I think you've gotta
know what you're good at.
The reality is,
I watch so many people try
to fix their shortcomings,
and I wish they would triple
down under super strengths,
where I think would just
be far better for them.
(upbeat music)
This deepfake thing really is fascinating.
If you think about AI's advancement,
I'm like, "Wow."
We're talking about a
half decade from now,
where this shit's gonna be perfect,
and now what?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Are we only in a place where,
it's so funny,
the openness of the internet
was something I understood.
I think we're gonna see a big,
I feel like I'm gonna be
live streaming at all times
to prove it's me and what I have to say.
Everybody thinks it's gonna close.
I even just starting
saying, "the close-ness."
My counter-move to the
close-ness is complete on-ness.
- [Man] Yeah.
There's-
- [Gary] If I stream
every minute of my life,
there should be no
debate if I ever said it
because it's documented
if I did or didn't.
I can prove that I didn't.
You've been watching at all times.
Some Truman Show shit.
What's your hot take on that?
I know you're a guest,
but what do you think?
- [Man] We've spent this time,
I wanna say we, I mean all of us.
We've all spent this era of
being used to the idea of
if it's on video, it happened.
Eye-witness footage,
that's the thing that scares me,
especially from international
places where we don't actually
have a window in necessarily
'cause there's not a free press.
And now we're gonna be having,
or have this new dynamic that's coming in.
We're gonna have to evaluate
everything on this new level.
- Yeah.
- [Man] We're not,
the world is not ready for that.
- No, because as you know,
that means people are gonna
go into their prejudices.
- [Man] Yeah.
- By having the ability to say deepfake,
now you can basically
say that didn't happen.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Right?
This horrific bullshit
of the police in Phoenix.
If you want to be on the side of racism,
you can just say that's a bullshit video.
- [Man] Yeah.
- That fuckin' hurts.
I agree, listen.
- [Man] That's the scary part.
- There's a complete
restructuring of our society
in our faces right now.
Nationalism on the rise.
Deep, to your point,
that's a great way to put it.
We've lived for a hundred
years on the assumption of
if it's on film it's true,
and we're about to enter the
era of that not being true.
(percussive music)
- I often talk about being a shield
to give them courage.
I'm very proud that especially
for a lot of immigrant kids,
or a lot of people,
I'm giving them permission.
I'm creating,
I'm so comfortable with
judgment against me,
that I'm giving them
room to try something.
If it fails, they can say,
"Well, Gar."
I wanna take the blame for
them to give them the step.
My observation from afar is you
do that for a lot of people.
I think that is an
incredible gift to give.
When I say that,
when I frame that up,
does that make sense to you?
Do you understand what I'm saying?
- Yeah, absolutely
- Tell me
how you observe that.
- Because, Gary,
I always say that the single
best moment of my life,
and by the way, this
wasn't a single moment.
It was a gradual realization.
But, the best moment
of my life was the day
that I realized I no longer
give a damn what anybody thinks.
- Go figure.
- And that is the only way
to live your life.
- Preach.
- I especially communicate
that message to women,
because from the moment
we're born as women,
everything around us conspires
to make us feel insecure
about absolutely everything
to do with ourselves.
- Yeah, the infrastructure.
- The way we look,
the way we talk,
the way we dress.
Nice girls do this,
nice girls do that.
Women spend the rest of our
lives coming back from that.
Some of us never do.
I wanna shortcut that
process for every woman,
but also to your point,
for everybody who is worried
about what other people think,
because honestly,
- Which is everybody.
- Which is so funny but dopey,
because that's the worst way to be.
- Cindy, I think,
I also observed this, again,
'cause we don't know each other that well.
I observe this from you as well,
which I really appreciate.
At times when people have
been at a dinner table
and your name gets brought up,
this is what happens to me, too,
and I go, "Be careful.
If you watch her interact,"
and I'm proud of this as well.
One thing that I think
you do extremely well
is not giving a fuck what anybody thinks
does not mean you do
not hear other people.
- Oh, no. Absolutely.
- But that's a point of clarity.
This is not audacity.
- No, you're right.
Don't give a damn what other
people think in a good way.
- That's right.
- Live your life and work your work
according to your values
and what you believe in.
- I have watched
you do a really good job of
bringing awareness to things
to put pressure,
or to bring conversation.
I've watched you bring
awareness to something,
"Hey, this is not accept,"
Tweet, "I don't like this."
Or, "What's our take on this?"
Whatever it may be.
I've watched people that are
on the receiving end of that.
Ninety-nine percent of
the time an audiencer.
Of the left one percent,
point nine percent of
'em defend with bullshit.
- Yeah.
- But occasionally,
I've seen in that point
one percent remaining,
somebody giving clarity, context,
and you were extremely
quick to also hear it.
This is not you rallying,
people rallying a mob, it pisses me off.
- Mm.
- I've watched you,
and I do the same thing.
Sometimes people say something to me,
friend of mine, Ted, the other day said,
"Hey, I don't like your
definition of an entrepreneur.
By nature, you're not one.
I watched the video."
And I'm like, "He's right.
"I work for my dad.
"This definition of
never working for anybody
"is not a good definition.
"I need to clarify."
I'm a little worried about,
I'm trying to protect
over entrepreneurship.
In that, I can get excited sometimes,
and you're throwing out headlines.
It was an incredible back-and-forth where,
and I've seen that from you,
and that,
for me,
is why I so desperately
wanted you here today.
It's why for me
- Well, thank you.
- I adamantly support
a lot of what you do.
Talk about that.
Not giving a fuck,
but actually having the capacity to hear
when somebody has a
counterpoint that may penetrate
your psyche as you're going
through the conversation.
- Well, I think,
What I'd say to that, Gary,
is when you don't actually
care what other people think,
that frees you up to hear people for real.
- Yeah, I agree.
- As opposed to worrying all the time
about what other people think,
and therefore having that
lens obscure the truth
of something you should
be looking at differently.
(percussive music)
- So many people on this-
- Yeah.
- Gary. Jim Stengel.
- Hey, cutie.
- Hey, buddy.
- How are you?
- Good, man.
- Dude, I'm so excited
about your podcast
- Good to see you.
- It's awesome.
- Are you enjoying it?
- Oh my god, I love it.
Much more than I thought I would.
- Dude.
- It's just fun.
- That just gave this, look.
Goosebumps.
You know why?
I haven't even started,
- I know.
- I wanted the first ten.
This is Harriet, Loren's com.
She runs comms at the inner x.
- Hi, I'm Harriet Flory.
Nice to meet you.
- Oh, hi.
- Hi.
- Jim's doing a podcast with-
- Yes.
- We doin' five this week?
I'm here tomorrow afternoon, man.
(beep)
- [Jim] I'm Jim Stengel,
and my mission in life is to help brands
find a purpose and activate it.
Earlier in my life,
I was the Proctor & Gamble
Chief Marketing Officer
looking out over hundreds
of brands around the world.
You may not know it,
but the CMOs of all of
your favorite brands
are really trying to bring
purpose to life in their brands.
And on this show,
we're gonna learn their lessons,
how they delve into it.
And you're also gonna
learn about the habits,
practices, and rituals of
these remarkable people
and how they work,
and how they play,
and how they thrive.
Right here on The CMO Podcast.
(beep)
(upbeat music)
(computer audio plays)
- A lot of people don't want to know
the exact roadmap, right?
They wanna know if you have
confidence where you got it.
So you're saying, "I
got it from my parents."
But then, not in the same breath,
but in the same conversation
you're saying fuck your parents.
What if you don't have that
support to make that confidence,
where does that come from?
- Everybody's gonna have
different situations
and different serendipities.
It's not just my parents.
I got self-esteem injected from my mom,
which is a huge variable,
which is why I put her on a huge pedestal.
And to your point, not
everybody gets that.
Somebody may get that
later from their spouse.
I would argue if my dad was here,
he would tell you
that any progression
in his self-confidence
came when I came into his life
and started making him
feel like he did something,
because he grew up under a mom who didn't
give him confidence.
So, at the same token to your point,
when I'm saying, "Fuck your parents,"
I'm saying it's more of a way
to break through to kids to say,
"Look, you need to lean in to your truth.
"You need to have empathy
for why your parents
"are giving you the advice.
"But, the reality is,
"this is gonna be your life,
"and you're gonna have to
deal with the ramifications."
By the way,
even though my mom
or somebody else who's lucky
enough to have a mom instill
enormous amounts of self-esteem into them,
doesn't mean that same mom
may not have an ideological
point of view on you being a doctor.
That's not one or the other.
They're carved out, separate things.
And back to the point of all of this.
I think one of the biggest things
that I'm really excited about clarifying
in the next half decade is
I don't think I'm right about anything.
I think that I'm right for me.
I read a lot of feedback.
These are observations from
one man's point of view.
You need to take it and
understand what to do with it.
One of the things I'm most
passionate about right now
is there's a lot of cultures,
especially in Asia and
India and other places,
where not listening to your parents
is a massive disrespect.
Massive problem.
It's being disobedient.
The amount of times
that I've seen the word
not behaving and being disobedient
has been unbelievable in
the last two, three months.
They're like,
"Gary, you don't understand.
"I can't do that.
"That is a death blow."
And I'm like,
"You don't understand.
"That's exactly what you need to do,
"because here's the alternative.
"You're gonna be 39 years old
"walkin' to your parents
fuckin' living room
"for some nice tea and tell
them to go fuck themselves
"and never talk to them again."
I'm trying to save relationships
by telling people to
fight their parents now,
because what always
happens in this scenario
is it dies later.
Right?
Then they marry somebody.
That spouse loves them and they're like,
"Don't let your parents
control your life."
It becomes all fucked up
with the mother-in-law
and the sister-in-law,
and the mother-in-law,
fuck.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- What's way better is
go do what you wanna do.
But, then deal with the ramifications.
The other shoe in my conversation
of go do what you want,
is if you go on and fail,
you have to give the point to the parents.
(laughter)
That's the part that
nobody wants to hear of.
Go fuck your parents is super fun.
When your parents wanted
you to do something
but you didn't have self-awareness
and you just wanted to be like me
and you started a fuckin'
start-up company and you fail,
you have to be okay with going back and,
not necessarily saying
your parents were right,
'cause you never wanted to be a doctor,
but acknowledging you lost.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Delusion doesn't work.
It leads to depression.
- [Woman] Yeah.
(solemn guitar music)
- Thanks, Jimmy.
Wish you nothin' but the best, bro.
It's your for real time.
Thank you guys.
Take care.
Bye-bye.
(laughs) So good.
- [Videographer] Will you
give them a little context
about the hills?
- Hey, guys.
That was just me on the Jim Rome Show.
Rome is burning.
One of the iconic sports
personalities of all time.
I was on the show three
years ago just like this,
outside of Cannes.
He loved it.
It was the first time I was on his show.
We had dinner in L.A. once or twice.
I like him.
He was very gracious to
give me a platform today
to talk about our Topps partnership.
If you're watching this
video or listening to it,
if you don't know,
Topps Series 2, Gary Vee,
Gary Vee's top entrepreneurs in baseball,
one of the most exciting
things I've ever done.
I highly recommend you go
out to your local hobby store
or Topps.com or Walmart, Target,
and buy a couple of packs.
Let me know if you pulled a Gary Vee card.
You can probably tell by my tone,
literally one of the greatest
fuckin' things I've ever done.
(pensive music)
(percussive music)
- We're 20/20 challenge.
We're coming up with the
campaign that needs to launch
by September.
- [Gary] On Alexa.
- Run for 18 months,
- On Alexa, too.
- It's a voice strategy and a AWS campaign
with creative technology.
It's not just a scale for technology.
It's an overall campaign.
- Pretty sexy.
- Save the world.
Similar to Global Citizen last year.
- Bring as much awareness to it
to actually save the world.
- Is this feasible?
Can it launch?
Will people care?
That was my thing this morning,
'cause they were telling me their idea.
I said, "No one's gonna use this."
You can say that, too.
Because I think that
if they launch an idea
that solves the problem but
isn't engaging or encouraging
for people to actually not just use once
but repeatedly engage with and care about-
- Well, then that means it's
not solving the problem.
- Exactly.
- Its ambition
is to solve the problem.
- Right.
So they were arguing with me, but-
- The consumer will speak in the end.
- I said, "You might win, the
judges might like your idea,
"but you're not gonna win if
it doesn't actually launch
and isn't,"
so go-to-market strategy
is important as well.
- Trophies aren't fun
when your business sucks.
- Preach point.
Like it.
(upbeat music)
- Have you guys spent any time
on trying to tackle the fact
that it's become a political issue?
I think the biggest issue,
when I do these things,
I actually want to try
to do something about it.
I'm not just here for the
sake of a competition.
I think the biggest issue with climate
is not collecting data.
It's that half the world has
decided it's not an issue.
Because the politics of that country
or that side of the country has decided.
Has there been anything for you to,
have you debated that?
Because I think one of
the things that you might,
great, so you're gonna have
a massively tiny percentage
of the most extreme social
liberal people in each society
get so compelled that they're
gonna do the actual work,
but that's gonna be a very,
very, very small group.
I'm wondering,
has there been any discussion
of that truth amongst you,
and has there been any comms planning
or any debating amongst you to,
not how we're gonna convince people
that the powers of core
matters or climate matters,
but maybe galvanize
the 50 percent that do.
I believe in it very heavily.
I will never do this.
Not because I don't believe,
but because I don't like to do that,
I don't wanna do work.
One tough thing with a lot of
extremely social liberal people
is a lot of them are also affluent,
and they wanna use money instead of doing.
For example, I wanna save the world,
just like any good person.
But, I wanna use my money
to do that, or influence.
Not actually do work.
So, for example, playing that out,
one of the things that
we may recognize here
is this may skew very young.
As activism and doing the
right thing has become cool,
younger,
18 year-old me did not have as much money,
but did want to be cool,
so I would think a lot
about communication here,
of getting people that
will actually do it.
How do we make this a status symbol?
See where I'm going?
Could really give you a chance
of making this actually happen.
Because the biggest issue
with things like this
is you're telling us through communication
that you should be doing this.
And immediately, how
humans actually work is,
"Fuck you.
"My mom has cancer.
"The fuck are you telling me
"to take pictures of the fuckin' world?"
That's what we're losing on big issues.
Doesn't work.
That's why we have nationalism
and extreme rightness growing.
We did a lot of this for 15 years,
and nobody liked it.
And now we have the,
so this has no shot
unless you're thoughtful
about either building status in the youth,
and then they'll do the work.
Because everybody else
who won't believe in it
is too affluent and doesn't wanna do work.
Everybody else believes
in it but isn't affluent
and is older,
is just trying to make ends meet.
Very important.
This is why all these things die.
We're not empathetic
in our little meeting here.
Yeah, so think about that,
I think that will help you have a,
you see where I'm going with that?
It's a good perspective.
You probably could tell by
the way I'm articulating it.
I spend a lot of time thinking about that.
A lot of that.
'Cause I want so many things
to happen in the world,
but most of my friends
that see it the same way,
they go into pontificating and scolding
instead of actually trying to get it done.
That's the danger.
This requires work.
Ten photos?
Fifty photos?
Badges within an ecosystem,
that doesn't mean anything.
It fuckin' means nothing.
Right?
How are you gonna make
that connection point?
That's super important to me.
- By status,
do you mean how do we give them-
- Let me give you a left field thing.
How do we make a hoodie
and then put it on a bunch
of rappers and soccer players
and other things that matter,
and then people find out,
actually the only way
you can get that hoodie
is if you use this app and
get to the badge level.
You gotta make the hoodie cool.
Having 50 point badge,
to your point earlier,
we're gonna incentivize
with the Amazon actions.
I do think that works.
I like where you went with that.
My intuition, though,
is monetary value won't be enough
on such an altruistic thing.
But, having a limited edition hoodie
that everybody thinks is, you know?
See where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- Think people have to think more.
I always dream about,
- One minute-
- People wanna use Beyonce
and all these people,
and I'm like,
"I would probably have
Beyonce wear something crazy
"when she makes the announcement."
Make it about that thing,
like what you're wearing, which is rad.
And then hope everybody wants it.
Then we tell the world,
"Oh, you want that?
"Here's how."
See where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- Because this, out of all of them,
has a lot of friction.
You're asking people to do a lot.
You're relying on incentives and badges.
We need those things to
mean something first,
otherwise nobody does anything.
Fortnite meant something first,
then you can do gamification.
Not the other way around.
- You have to work, I understand.
- Good.
- We don't have the exact answer-
- You don't need to, right?
To meet with only 10 minutes.
It's funny, I don't
come here to check a box
or 'cause I like Michelle.
I wanna really bring value.
What I'm trying to do here,
I think I did.
Which is, I'm listening.
Then I'm like,
"Okay, it's this,
"now you can go back,
"and that's what you need to work on."
That's all fine in the ending, but...
It's the biggest problem on social issues.
We're trying to convince
people to change their mind
who are worried about making ends meet.
You think somebody who's making
entry-level salaries cares
about the Paris Accord?
They do not.
It's third-generation wealthy people.
You understand?
Or, the youth.
But, the youth will change its mind fast.
So, we have to make it cool.
Status.
Got it?
- Yes.
- That's why I believe companies
have the biggest chance
to change the world.
'Cause you're wearin'
that Polo for a reason.
You're trying to communicate.
That's what fashion has, right?
It's my argument on plastic bottles.
I keep telling people,
"As long as Fiji and Smartwater is status,
"you're not changing jack shit."
Status.
Got it?
- Got it.
- Cool.
Awesome.
- Okay, thank you.
- Thank you.
- So much.
- Thank you, very much.
- Nice to meet you.
(music slows)
(dramatic music)
- [Audience Member] The
classic art director,
copy righter team model,
since you guys have your
crazy wild, wild, west
What's App with the client,
how do you feel about the copy righter
and the art director working together-
- We love it.
- Does that still work for you?
- Yeah.
The one thing that we have,
is every account,
and we don't have this
everywhere all the way yet
because we're just rolling this out,
but we're really close now.
Every account has threefold time creatives
one hundred percent dedicated to the logo,
even when it's a $500,000 fee account
and that person is a copy person,
a design person,
and then what we call a shreditor.
She or he is
doing film and
post-production as one person.
Kind of what D-Rock does for me.
Again, as you can imagine,
that production value when you're making
five thousand pieces of content
is not necessarily the films that...
It's native.
It's the shit that you actually like
when you're consuming content,
and some of it can be very
high production value,
and we just chop a bunch down.
Some of it could be grab your iPhone,
make this video on the
counter and post it.
They are there.
Above them are teams,
art and copy,
CDs.
What's happening is the core creator team
is very allocated a hundred
percent on one account.
As you go up, those teams
are spread out more,
but they're all making,
the thing I put the most pressure
on Adam and Mike about is,
"I need you on the way to work,
"write a Tweet for
Budweiser or Rolling Rock."
to set the tone that
if our GCDs are making,
this is a making culture.
You have people that
start hitting GCD level
and never make a single
thing for seven, 10,
make a single thing.
One thing that I would
love for all of you to do,
is start a little side hustle
of starting to sell something
on Shopify and Amazon,
and then be the marketer of that.
Buy 50 t-shirts,
put it on Shopify,
but then go do ads on Instagram, Snap.
Buy a pre-wrote podcast
ad from a small podcast
and write the copy for the read.
Be a practitioner.
That's why I walk with such
audacity and confidence,
is I know nobody here does.
They'll get into a debate, I'm like,
"You're talking about an MMM.
"You're talking about Ipsos.
"You're talking about subjectiveness.
"I'm talking about truth."
It's always a very exciting conversation
to get into a debate with
somebody from the industry,
'cause they're living within the industry,
not what we're supposed to be doing.
It's ideology versus practicality.
Ideology always loses
unless you start making it practical.
Everybody wants everybody
else to change the world.
- I want to change the world.
- You can only do it by doing.
- I don't know how.
- That's what you have to practice.
- I know why, I have philosophy.
- Everybody knows why.
(laughter)
Everybody's got fuckin' ideas.
You have to do.
(somber music)
- Let's zoom out for just a moment,
because we're also still,
even focused on a campaign line tech,
'cause we're still
talking about marketing.
But, the human on the other
side is experiencing things
in ecommerce, in retail,
they're calling a call center,
they're dealing with a chat bot,
there's all this stuff-
- Yep.
- that they're touching.
And I guess my question is,
can we aspire to a world
where more of those things
are actually fueled by
the same intelligence
and approach?
Or, is it something that's too ambitious
to tie marketing and
customer experience together,
and really connect the dots around humans?
- It's gonna be required.
That's the beauty of innovation and truth.
Ultimately, it wins.
It didn't matter what all the
people with the medallions
on their taxis thought
about Uber in New York.
It happened.
It didn't matter what all the networks
thought about Netflix.
It happened.
It didn't matter what
Walmart thought about Amazon.
It happened.
What we plan on being one of the people
in this industry of doing,
and many others I hope follow,
and many of the people here,
I come here not to recruit or pontificate.
I come to inspire people
to build their own, independent shops,
so they can do the work
that they wanna be doing
versus what they have to be doing.
That's how we'll change the industry.
That's gonna happen with me or not.
I may have a chance to buy
the New York Jets next year,
and then I'll move on my merry way.
But, the reality is,
that will be a requirement
for this industry.
When you talk about the,
guys, how many normal people in life,
even know this week is happening?
(low rumbling)
(clicks tongue)
Zero.
Normal, end consumers have
no idea of this world,
the things we talk about.
They just live.
On brand is my favorite thing.
"Gary, that's off brand."
I'm like, "You decide?
"You, the brand manager,
"of the opinion of one
decide what's on brand
"because you interpreted a sentence
"which a copy righter wrote as
the brand that it stands for?
"And you've decided this
isn't aspirational living
"for the modern man?
"Get the fuck outta here."
(applause)
- All right, so-
- I apologize, but
yes, all of this is gonna matter.
I will say this.
Much of what I pontificate
around volume of creative,
being empathetic,
creating 30, 40 meaningful
cohorts to attack not one,
what is 18 to 35, are you kidding me?
The reason we have so
many issues with diversity
and gender issues in creative
is 'cause we have one 30 second spot.
What, are you gonna put everybody in it?
It's crazy.
We need a complete shift
in our mindset of creative.
We need to stop demonizing
quantity in this industry.
Quantity does not come expense of quality.
It's an excuse for those
who do not want to do.
We have a lot of things to work on.
- Gary, what is your favorite work?
- Empathy.
- It's very important.
- I think that empathy is something that,
obviously I've started a wine brand.
Somebody showed me a word
cloud three years ago,
and everybody thinks I'm
hustle and fuck and all this,
and sure enough,
in my word cloud,
analyzed every word for me.
Empathy, kindness, gratitude, patience.
I understand how I manifest
in my DNA on stage,
but the way I drive what I do day-to-day
internally and results,
is a hundred percent
predicated on empathy.
First, for my employees.
Second, for my clients' customers.
Third, for my clients.
That is a very different framework
than everybody else rolling around here,
which is why we will win in the end.
- On that note,
(applause)
Gary, I want to thank you.
Thank you, guys.
- Hi.
- Hello.
- We have two minutes?
Okay, I'm gonna go try to,
fear?
I think for me, because
I was an immigrant,
because I had bad grades,
my whole life I was losing,
that by the time I was a grown-up,
losing and fear didn't
mean anything to me.
I got lucky in so much
adversity as a child.
I think if you haven't had that,
or even if you have,
that you still fear it
because of the way your parents judged.
You have to practice.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- You have to practice doing
things that you are scared of.
It's very true.
When people talk to me about
fear it feels so heavy.
I'm like, "It's like
swimming or kissing a boy."
You were scared of that
when you were young
until you did it,
- [Woman] Very.
and then you weren't-
(laughter)
- Talking to me, right?
But then practice gets you there.
You have to practice
things that feel scary,
and then you'll get more used to them.
It's the truth.
It's just the truth.
- Will you take a picture?
- Yes.
(pensive music)
- [Blonde Woman] Tell me,
- [Gary] Yes.
- I've just had a very quick
briefing here from Harriet,
but I gather you've gotta
little bit of a different take
on the market than...
- A little bit of a different take, yes.
I think that we need a more
progressive conversation
on volume of creative,
that the industry needs to
start not demonizing quantity.
- Okay.
- This notion that quality
is given up when you do
a quantity of creative
is a huge misnomer,
and something that I think
would really benefit the industry,
and most of all the brands.
- How, in what way would it benefit?
- Most brands can't
make relevant creative,
because they're not making enough creative
to hit the many different cohorts
they need to be talking to,
so they end up making one
vanilla piece of video.
- I know exactly what you mean.
Don't speak because I
want to just get this done
in your great words.
- You got it.
- I'm sorry, "They're not
making enough creative
"to hit all the cohorts,
"so just making one
vanilla piece of work."
- We are too infatuated with reach,
and not enough around relevance.
If you don't make 70, 400, 3,000
pieces of meaningful content,
you could never create actual relevance.
- Yeah, okay.
- But, if you go walk
the streets right now,
one of the worst words
in the creative community
is volume and quantity.
- That's very true, yeah.
- That needs to,
we need to have a more thoughtful
conversation around it.
- Yeah, they're bad words at the moment.
- They are.
- Funny enough, I was at a
HBO session yesterday
where they were saying,
"How can you fix your output
without losing the secret source of HBO,
volume, and how can you do
that without sacrificing-"
- That, in the form of a one-hour drama
is a far more interesting debate than
trying to communicate a
toothpaste or a shampoo
or a soda-pop to the end consumer, right?
- Yeah.
- If I'm trying to sell,
what we know about long
form video theater,
movies, television,
is some shows are not meant for everybody.
We have four people here,
and that's okay.
- That's fine, yeah.
- Meanwhile, we have this
audacious conversation
that this 30 second spot is
supposed to make everybody
inspired to buy.
- That's very true.
- HBO does do a lot of creative.
- Yeah, they do.
- They have many different shows.
If HBO was a creative agency,
they would have one show.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
Yeah, yeah.
- I would say the inflection
points for me have been
the hiring or acquisitions
like PureWow and Ryan and Mary Kate.
It's just been people.
Our inflection point has just been people.
It's when I've made good decisions
instead of bad decisions,
of people who I can dance with
for a long period of time.
It's unbelievable to me
how much of the variable is casting.
I think about business
more and more everyday
like I think about sports, right?
When the Knicks had Clyde
Frazier and Willis Reed
and Earl the Pearl Monroe,
they won championships.
When they have the bums that
have been wearing the jerseys
for the last 25 years, they don't.
A lot of people talk
about teams as being good
and not good.
It's the casting within it.
We have a lot of the casting,
it's been the human decision-making.
It's been the 17 to 44 people
that have disproportionately
impacted the business,
and every time I made that right call.
And by the way, every time
I made the wrong call,
it's slowing down opportunity.
To me, it's very heavily
predicated on people.
- Totally.
(pensive music)
- Guys, the amount of you
that are not subscribed to
this channel is devastating.
Please, subscribe and leave a comment.
Let me know how you liked
the three day mash-up.
We're always listening.